what frustrated me the most or kind of
gave me that fire was the fact that when
I was hospitalized in the mental health
facility I was not allowed to walk I was
on wheelchair rest it was very
dehumanizing that and also you know
having to pretty much strip down to my
knickers you weren't even allowed to
wear a bra because you could put stuff
in to make you weigh more you know my
mother hasn't seen me that naked in
years kind of thing that was my lowest
and I just thought I'm not doing this
[Music]
anymore hi
hi so firstly I kind of want to get into
the definition of what um bdd is I think
it would be really good if you kind of
went around and and gave your own
definition of what it means to you I
think for me it means you know a
fixation on a certain part of your body
or multiple parts of your body um that
that kind of overwhelms you takes over
your enti entire life sometimes I would
say it's like an obsession with certain
parts of your body so similar to to what
you're saying it's an obsession and it's
an obsession to change yourself as well
even at your own detriment you lose
sight of everything else um and it can
be very toxic and very unhealthy for me
it was a lot about my self identity
tying into this thing that I perceived
wasn't right with me so I I didn't think
I was muscular enough I didn't feel like
I looked the way I was supposed to look
and that wasn't just uh my body doesn't
look right it's I'm wrong there's not
something not right with me that's what
it
meant yeah for me um it
was uh like looking into a distorted
like looking through disorted glasses um
I couldn't think about anything else it
literally took every second up from my
day um it felt like a dark cloud came
over me and weighed me down um I
couldn't just live I I it just took
every moment up for me it's having quite
a low self- opinion um of
oneself um never feeling like you are
enough feeling like you've got heavy
weight attached to your ankle that
you're dragging around that can really
take away that spark and that happiness
and uh yeah it's very
consuming it was something that you know
made me feel shame
embarrassed um stopped me from living my
teenage years to the fullest and kind of
like robbed me of my joy quite a lot um
and was yeah really
oppressive um a heaviness and obsession
is there a specific point you can trace
back to or recall when you started to
become fixated on your appearance um so
I was 14 years old when I was diagnosed
with body dysmorphic disorder I was
already diagnosed with dep depression
and anxiety but I had a fixation on
getting a flat stomach because I was
bullied for being overweight so um I
just thought okay if I'm thin I'll be
happier and in the end it became a
full-blown anorexia um to the point
where I was uh hospitalized and I was
told either either you go inv
voluntarily or with Section you um I'm
5'8 which is 170 cm
and at my lowest point I weighed 33
kilos Which is less than five Stone and
uh the doctors told my parents I had two
weeks to live so the body body
dysmorphia almost killed me I think
because of my childhood experiences just
coming from a dysfunctional home um had
an alcoholic father um I was searching
for like my identity and I didn't really
have anybody to really affirm me and
kind of like say oh you know you're
beautiful you know um you're loved and
things like that um consistently so I
think that's where that kind of
self-doubt was seeping in um the years
progressively went on and then I believe
I was about 13 and that's when I feel
like things started to kick off for me
cuz you're right in um you know school
and you know pre peir pressure and Body
Image stuff you know seeps out and um
that's when I started to become really
obsessed with my facial features and
just became
self-conscious um and really obsessive
with exercise and just consistently
wanting to lose weight CU I thought that
if I lost a lot of weight then my face
would change and it's just a never
ending cycle but I didn't actually
understand that it was body dysmorphic
disorder so as the years went on um I
kind of again was seeking validation and
unhealthy relationships and I ended up
um getting into an emotionally abusive
relationship and as you can imagine if
you're with somebody that kind of just
beats you down like verbally all the
time um it can make it worse I then
developed Bia because I was just
consistently trying to lose the weight I
was really really depressed and that
continued to about the age of
21 which is well actually 19 which is
when I went to the doctors they didn't
really listen so I went another like 2
three years just battling with it and
had to literally beg you know break down
and say like look there's something
wrong with me I really need help and um
for me that's kind of when my journey
began to get a lot better and I think
like my relationship with God um as a
Christian actually helped me Propel
forward so my experience with bdd
started when I was uh 14 uh previous to
that I'd had 3 or four years uh
experiencing
OCD um before I I started to from BD but
nothing really prepared me for for the
impact this illness would have on me
just just to give some context
beforehand I was I loved playing
rugby um I was doing well at school um I
had friends um and you know things were
going really well um but as soon as kind
of I turned
14 my whole life started change I was
spending hours in the mirror um I just
couldn't get out of it I couldn't stop
myself looking and
scrutinizing and pulling myself apart
and I think
that's what makes bdd so difficult it's
so individual you're literally pulling
yourself apart every single day for
hours on end and when you spend you know
10 hours a day in the mirror staring at
yourself um it's going to going to have
an impact as I as I found out and
unfortunately I became so unwell uh that
I had to drop out school and uh I became
housebound for 6 months um um which was
probably one of the most excruciatingly
painful times of My Life um getting up
really
early 6:00 a.m. spending hour in the
mirror purging my
food um picking up my skin moisturizing
continuously taking multiple photos of
myself scrutinizing them photos and then
repeat and repeat and repeat over and
over again um and I'm not embarrassed to
say you know after after six months of
doing that every every single day
um you know I unfortunately tried to
take take my own life um and you know
it's important to talk about these
things uh but luckily I I I survived uh
evidently um and from that point I
started to build again but it just shows
that bdd can take away your education it
can take away your health it can take
away your entire life um but I'm lucky
that I got the support I needed a lot of
resonate with so much what you were
saying I think that there's there's a
lot of people when they think about
people having body dysmorphic disorder I
think there's this idea of vanity or you
just you just want to look good and all
this kind of there's a negative kind of
connotation that comes with it but you
you don't choose to to do these
compulsive behaviors because they're not
nice you know when you're doing it it's
it's really horrible and like don't feel
like you're alone cuz I would say it
drove me to try and kill myself myself
twice so yeah I'm I'm definitely in the
same boat I'm glad you're here so I'm
glad you're here for me so much of it
revolved around masculinity and feeling
like as a young boy I needed to be a
specific person when I grew up to be a
man and the way that I found that when I
was younger was through rugby similar to
you Danny uh and I was the rugby guy in
my school it's all I spoke about it's
all I did and then when I was 13 I
fractured my spine playing rug be and
I've got metal in it now holding it
together and I just felt this entire
loss of respect and selfworth and I felt
like who I was had just disappeared
overnight when the doctor told me I
wasn't allowed to play anymore I gained
a significant amount of weight whilst I
was off for a year and I miss school for
the whole year as well and when I went
back to school you know I don't think
anyone bullied me but people definitely
treated me differently um from I think
partially probably just because I've
been away for a year but for me I
attributed all that to my body and
so I started trying to lose weight I
started reading about nutrition started
reading about exercise started um
running on treadmills and just trying to
lose weight somehow kind of came to the
fitness industry and started looking
online and seeing all these Fitness
influences and every man in that world
had big arms six-pack big chest veins
you know everyone looked the same way so
I just accepted this is what I'm
supposed to look like and there's this
kind of streak throughout that that
world that Fitness World of these
masculine ideas of are you man enough to
do this can you take enough pain to get
to this body you know it's it's all on
you the onus is all on you to be tough
enough and strong enough and push
yourself um and it got to the point
where I failed enough times I couldn't
do the the workout I you know couldn't
stick to the diet or even just the
workout wasn't as successful as it had
been the week before and whenever that
happened I had that overwhelming sense
of lack of selfworth and it's because
I'm a failure I can't do this and just
led to this locking myself away and just
feeling bad about myself um and that
happened enough times and for long
enough that I basically accepted that it
wasn't worth me being here and that
people around me would have a it would
be a better world if I didn't exist
because everyone that I followed on
Instagram could do this every day and I
couldn't um I'm not personally religious
myself but um I always think this was
such an amazing coincidence or whatever
it was maybe it was some kind of divine
thing but one of my best friends at Uni
came to my house on the day that I was
going to do it um oh sorry
uh and yeah and that I've kind of never
looked back since really she I broke
down in tears in front of her and she
told me that I should speak to someone
and I ended up getting a counselor
ironically I worked as a personal
trainer whilst I was getting counseling
even though I you know was really
struggling with my eating and my
exercise myself
um yeah I've done a full story there but
uh yeah I think it's really interesting
what you said between and I don't know
if everyone else feels like this this
kind of division between success and
failure right we put so much emphasis on
the way we look you know if you go on
Instagram you go on Twitter you go on
Facebook if that's still a thing I'm not
sure it is how you like an old person
saying that but um you know there's so
much emphasis on how you look getting
them likes you know
and we do associate with success and
fair I don't know what everyone else
feels about
that I thought that my life would be so
much better if I looked a certain way
and actually I got to that point and I
was miserable I'd never been that low in
my life I feel like that's the cruelty
of body dysmorphia because it's like a
vicious cycle and until that cycle is
broken it's like you're going to be
stuck in that Loop like you know um and
it's the obsession with obviously the
outward appearance um however I think
something that I've been able to learn
especially like linking to my faith is
that I feel like the character is what
last longer so everything within
yourself is what's going to last longer
you know cuz anything can happen
overnight something can happen to your
physical looks and things like that and
if that's what you're built on it's not
a firm foundation um so I think as I've
kind of like grown older and and healed
that's kind of something that's really
kept me grounded so I would say it was a
gradual process it wasn't like it just
happened overnight um I actually suffer
with OCD as well um have done since I
was eight um and I'd
say when I was around 16 it got on top
of me I didn't really know what B bdd
was I thought it was about being skinny
if I'm being honest I didn't that's sort
of The Stereotype I just knew that i' as
preoccupation I fell into this
compulsion of filming myself um beauty
of having an iPhone well not really is
that it's there 24/7 and it became this
compulsion where I would fill myself up
to 50 times a day and then rewatch it
and analyze every single frame um and
there was a particular day it was
actually my prom um I fil myself again
um or my family were going to come
around and as you do I was with my all
my friends and I couldn't go I had a
really massive panic attack um I just
thought I looked disgusting and horrible
um and
then during I'd say that was like that
was in 2019 um end of 2019 it got really
bad and then Co
happened um like we were all were locked
inside I had all that time and to film
myself to look in the mirror it just got
worse and worse and worse um to the
point where I couldn't even be around my
family I would hide my face with hoodies
and
makeup um I started
to use I go on social media and compare
myself to everyone um I would even
search up celebrities without makeup on
and screenshot them and I was would
compare myself constantly um I would
sear up plastic surgeries to get um I
had an app on my iPad where um I had a
picture of myself and I was drawing all
the surgeries I wanted to have done on
my face um and then there there was one
night that I just completely had enough
and uh that was the first time I had of
suicidal thought um and I felt really
guilty about it that was the biggest
thing um and the thought of telling
someone scared me um and I just felt
like my parents would worry obviously um
so I couldn't do that my bdd was
centered around my face um and my nose
especially and my jawline and I thought
the only way I can control
is losing weight so that's what I did I
restricted um starved myself I lost two
Stone
within 6 months I think um but it was
never enough just got worse and worse
um and then I was in therapy for my OCD
at the time um and I thought I'm just I
just have to have to talk about it I was
really embarrassed but I just have to
talk about it and I did with my
therapist and she said that sounded like
bdd um I was I was relieved cuz it's
like there's something in my head it was
I was just ugly I was disgusting there
I'm not ill there there's not an illness
I'm just
disgusting um and she directed me to the
bdd foundation um which is where
everything changed really for me uh I
realized it's it's I have to do the same
thing I do to be OCD with bdd um which
was starving the Beast not giving to it
cut out the compulsion of fing myself
which was the hardest thing to do um but
as I did that I realized I wasn't
grabbing the phone as often I wasn't
even thinking about it as often um and I
did Erp which was terrifying and awful
but is the best thing that I ever did I
met a community on
Instagram um people sharing their
experiences like ke um have really
helped me um I think that's the biggest
thing that's helped me really is knowing
there other people going through it um
cuz you feel so alone and I felt so
alone I was always that awkward kid I
was really a loner and as time's gone on
and I've I've had my Therapies in later
life and I've reflected back I've always
been that highly sensitive boy and with
being highly sensitive comes that real
awareness I pick up everything energies
I read people I I know how to adapt I
know when to remove myself I know if
someone's in pain I almost like feel
their pain and that's it's it's a good
thing but also it can really wear you
down but I've always been that guy
that's aware um but my younger life I
was very much a loner I didn't have many
friends I didn't really want many
friends I was just in my own little
bubble and that's my safe space but
obviously as we get older we have to
start venturing at our comfort zones and
school was a very turbulent place for me
as I got into secondary school bullying
always being that Target because I was
always on my own and if there was an
opportunity to go home at lunch I'd go
home with a low self-esteem already now
cuz I'd had quite a rough
time I was really anxious and the
anxiety was there and oh my god I've got
to fit in again and this is I just
wanted to be homeschooled or I didn't
want to do school I made a friend and he
was very similar to me in the sense of
uh loved his music and he was theatrical
and quite camp and he was a little bit
of a Target himself I really resonated
with him and so I just stuck with him
but then that made us both the targets
because I was the new boy he had already
built up a bit of a reputation for not
being one of the typical Lads in an old
boy school and there started a whole new
wave of bullying always being called the
gay boys and back then at school which
is 20 plus years ago now that was like
one of the worst things to be called you
didn't want to be called that and if
word got around that you might be a
Nancy boy or you know not one of the
lads you were the target so the cycle
started again and this low self-esteem
was always there weirdly the only ways
Essex which is a reality TV show hit and
I became obsessed with that show it was
bizarre to me what it was everyone was
talking about it it was this new genre
of TV structured reality
I identified with a lot of the guys on
the show in the sense of what my life
was but I thought oh my god wow these
are like these guys are cool and I
became really fixated on the show as a
lot of us
were and um any to fans no yes no yes um
anyway it really was a big thing they
were basically looking for locations to
film in and I rocked up and long long
long long story short they met me one of
The Producers really me and found me
interesting 3 months later I get a call
and they
say uh would you like to come and uh
meet one of our exact producers we think
you could be quite interested on coming
on the show like tell us more about you
my whole life just changed overnight
because by what I've said I was always
in a bubble and I was always very in
control of my bubble and when I got the
opportunity to go on the show there was
that element of oh my God this is going
to be a moment for me everything I've
idolized and wanted maybe quietly in a
fantasy has just come through my door
and I'm going to give it a go and I
wanted to feel like what these guys were
living the dream I wanted that so I did
it and with that came hundreds of
thousands of people following you on
Twitter was the thing at the time
everyone had an opinion on you everyone
was talking about you the show was done
in a way that we would film it and 2
days later it would be out for the
public to watch it was such a quick turn
around what it did do was it put my
image and how I saw myself right at the
Forefront because I was in this very
unique bubble it was very competitive
everyone wanted to look a certain way
there was this High glossy approach that
everyone wanted to have that Perfection
the body's the tan becoming obsessive
about fake tan um muscles getting the
photo shoots looking at they' run polls
about who your favorite cast member was
and if you ranked low I'd see it and I'd
be like oh my God like why people don't
like me and it brought back all those
feelings of that young boy that didn't
feel liked or wanted so what can I do I
need to up my game I need to get this
pressure on me and I want to be one of
these I want to be like the best cuz I
always had that in my in my head people
were like he's gay he's gay he's gay um
so after a couple of years on the show
and the constant scrutiny of being on on
that I decided that I needed to remove
myself because I was getting very
unhappy obsessing about myself before
filming looking at myself in the mirror
going to social media needing the
Selfies the
validation um just constantly in that
cycle and it's draining as we all know
it's it's it's never ending and in that
period That's when I did identify with
my sexuality I met a guy and I did come
out as gay I came out live on this
morning it was again under the glare of
the media but I felt like people had
followed my story for such a long time
that it was only right that I then gave
them my truth and my struggles with
identifying with myself but then with
that and my nature embarked on this
whole new chapter because I was now 30
years old just come out never had a
relationship in my life never had
intimate relations in my life and all of
a sudden I'm this gay guy in the public
eye and I thought I needed to be Mr
jacked up muscles physique because I
didn't want to be seen as less than the
man that you know I I wanted to be seen
as Mr masculine still because there was
this this internal homophobia I would
say towards myself and so I went on that
mission and it was all about the
magazines of looking at all these guys
that had the wash Bard stomachs and the
big muscles and the tats and hence I did
all of this I went on this total Rebrand
we go into that coid period and during
that coid period I was on my own which
was a dangerous thing I didn't realize
at the time but I thought that's what I
needed to do but in that year window
when we were all housebound the mirror
the social media became the enemy to the
point where it was hours every day
looking at myself getting a pencil
drawing on my nose and I became obsessed
with my nose that I felt like I had to
change it cuz it was still too big for
my face it had a dent in it um if I've
been this successful up to this point
with this face imagine what it would be
like if I was totally confident with
that straight masculine nose I as soon
as we came out that first lockdown I go
to Harley Street I go and see a top
surgeon he looks at my face he says your
nose is too big for your face proportion
wise you're a good-looking boy but the
nose we can make you better I was like
yes you validated my insecurity there
sign me up get me on that table fix my
nose no real duty of care to that apart
from yeah you can make me better because
I was in a vulnerable place and so I did
I did the surgery the surgery went wrong
and the surgery was a disaster and there
started a whole new chapter but I think
I'll leave it there for the minute but
it got me to the point of plastic
surgery without any real
intervention and I was about to embark
on a chapter then which was where it all
came to light and why I'm sitting here
today A few of you have mentioned that
like I suppose bdd is often linked with
or or confused with like eating
disorders or other mental health
conditions do you think you could kind
of like talk about how they might
interact for me personally um I was
diagnosed with depression and that
obviously you I felt such a low kind of
self-esteem low selfworth why am I here
why was I born I don't sort of deserve
to exist and then that sort of fueled
the fire that became bdd because I would
then look at myself and it was almost
like looking in the mirror validated all
those things I'm not worthy and that
kind of thing that kind of triggered me
into okay maybe my life will be better
maybe I won't be so depressed if I lose
weight and then my focus was on my
stomach my thighs because I thought they
were too big um and even at a size zero
I thought I had thunder thighs I thought
my stomach was you know like that of a
whale so for me my mental illnesses
really contributed to getting bdd
because I had no self-esteem I had no
self-worth and also being diagnosed is
it can be quite triggering being told
that you're going to be on tablets for
the rest of your life because you have a
lack of
Serotonin that in itself is a lot to
take on at the age of 14 so for me my
mental health kind of fueled the fire
but I know it's not the case for
everyone I just it's exhausting even
thinking about it it's almost like
trying to being surrounded and trying to
fight on all fronts um and and
continuously just being bombarded with
different emotions I I I remember when I
was experiencing bdd just just feeling
differently every single day you know
one day I felt really anxious the next
day I'd be really depressed probably
because I've zoomed in on my appearance
or you know and and the next day I'd be
purging my food which could be linked to
an eating disorder it wasn't but it
could be linked to an eating disorder so
yeah it's so complex I don't know if
everyone else else feels that way too
like actually understanding it yourself
and getting your head around it is is
very difficult I think for me OCD makes
me really anxious and I have to do the
compulsions to sort of stop that anxiety
feeling whereas with the bdd I just felt
so sad and depressed and like I said
before weight is just on me and pulling
me down I just cried all the time there
was like a difference um between the OCD
and the bdd I think with eating
disorders I think um
you can have an eatting disorder and
have bdd and I think that's where people
get sort of confused is that bdd is a
separate illness
um just like OCD is to bdd they can be
very similar and they can have they can
sort of intertwine with each other but
they're separate some researchers saying
that it should actually be a form of
eaten disorder um
because some people's experiences the
eating actually is the primary issue I
think that most dis Moria itself exists
in that idea that the the criteria
within the diagnostic statistical manual
says that it can't be aligned with body
fat and it can't be kind of aligned with
disorder eating or or eating distress um
and I think that exists for some people
for for me personally mine did align
with body fat and mine did align with
eating distress because I was so
obsessed with trying to lose weight um I
would literally restrict myself from
eating and you know on days was super
hungry like I'm you know going out with
friends and then coming home and I'm
throwing up in the bathroom nobody knows
what I'm doing and stuff like that and
um it was because I was so obsessed with
wanting to lose the weight and then
feeling the guilt of just eating food I
felt so guilty and I thought oh my gosh
I'm you know my progress is going to you
know be destroyed if I eat a plate of
food when you know it's probably just
like a fraction of my daily intake um
but the guilt was always there so I feel
like they they were simultaneously
happening at the same time but
definitely believe that body body
dysmorphia was the first thing that I
was experiencing and I do think they're
called separate do you think it's a
Common Thread that we all need this
element of control on what we're doing
ab and we have to be consumed by that
control to almost tell ourselves that we
are in control of what we're doing and
we're actually okay the issue with me I
don't know if any of you guys suffer
from this but I've got an acute case of
perfectionism so it's kind of like um
yeah it's it's all like
Interlink yeah because you know if if I
achieve a certain level of something
then I'll be happy then I'll be
successful when actually you're chasing
the impossible cuz as humans we are not
perfect we're never going to be I think
that's a bit like about bdd is also it's
not just about how you look it's
self-image it's how you like sit how you
come across and I for me I also fixated
on like um education and if I didn't
reach a certain point I was so angry
with myself and I thought people it
would it's it's the image it's like how
do people perceive you and I had to be
perceived in a good way and it's
interesting how it intertwines with OCD
as well like you know talking about
perfectionism like you know I'll spend
an extra 2 hours in the office I'll work
16 hours a day because I just think I'm
trying to get that goal I want to be the
best I want to do better than everyone
else um and that's really hard and then
when you apply that to your image
M it's it's horrific it's it's literally
cuz you're never going to be perfect
you're never going to reach it every
time you look in that mirror I think
someone said earlier that you're you're
almost searching for the problem that's
not there if there's not a problem
you'll make it a problem for me it was
back in 2013 I didn't really have social
media like that and um it wasn't
something heard of I think when I was
growing up as a teenager whereas now
it's such a serious mental health issue
that we
it's a it's a term that shouldn't really
kind of like be thrown around and I feel
like um when I was diagnosed it was by a
psychiatrist so um not to say that
people can't kind of like um identify
with the symptoms but I think it's also
really important to go to the GPS even
though that's another story um or your
doctors or whatever to try and get a
diagnosis um so that you can get the
right help and not kind of like assume
that you have it just because you you
might link to other people's experiences
and stuff like I I get what you're
saying because I feel like now in the
age of social media especially like with
Tik Tok and stuff people are like self
diagnosing and then they start making
videos about oh I definitely have this
when actually you do need to go through
the correct kind of avenues and get a
proper diagnosis when I was anorexic I
was told that I was too fat to be
anorexic but I had all of the patterns
and and you know because it's a
psychological disorder that then
presents self as physical they're
talking about like people just throwing
these words around they also they use as
an adjective like you know especially
with OCD and stuff is that I'm so OCD
that makes no sense I'm so obsessive
compulsive disorder um so it's like and
it's so easily it's sort of like slang
now it's like with all these different
mental illnesses and um it shouldn't get
to the point where it's glamorized it
should get to the point where it's made
aware so it helps people um but I do
feel like there is a toxic side
especially on Tik Tok where it is 100 %
glamorized um yeah there's nothing
glamorous about this all agree like when
you actually experience this illness
there is nothing glamorous there's
nothing glamorous about visiting a a
psych w i reoccurring nightmares of do
like I yeah that terrifies me because
when you're that ill and you know
there's a part of you to know that I
could potentially be there it terrifies
you to your girl I read a statistic that
men are about 40% of people that have
bdd do you think there's a difference in
the way that like men and women perceive
it or that you're treated if you're a
man versus a woman yeah I I think number
one I think there's like a double stigma
with with men uh I never thought I'd say
this but you know men are men are under
represented in this in in this in this
specific area um it's not normally the
case in most areas but you know there is
that double stigma I remember when I
started talking about it's interesting
you mentioned a boys school cuz I went
to a boys school as well and you know
what it's like you know talking about
I'm worried about the way I look or you
know I'm worried that my nose is too big
or I'm worried that my hairline receding
and saying that to your mates or walking
into the rugby changing room and saying
you know I'm worried about my weight the
abuse you get I mean it's it's horrific
I I think one of the hardest things is
is just feeling like you shouldn't be
experiencing these emotions you
shouldn't be having these concerns about
the way you look and you definitely
shouldn't be getting treatment because
you're a man when I finally came through
my plastic surgery ordal and I'd gone
off radar I'd come off of the socials
people were wondering where I was and
whatever it was I just didn't want to be
seen I bumped into someone who who gave
me the opportunity to go on to a a
morning talk show and I did and I went
and basically said this is where I'm at
this is why I've disappeared for a while
and I had this surgery and it the
version of events should we say the
aftermath to that
feature that we did and me having that
candid
conversation I was overwhelmed by the
amount of men that came my way and not
just men part of my community within the
lgbtq plus but just men that must have
caught a clip of it or seen it and that
have reached out to me and and feel this
shame that they have this this low
self-esteem or they can't vocalize that
they're seeing themselves in a certain
way because it just seems seems less of
a it's not a masculine thing to talk
about or it's it's not a conversation
that you're going to sit over the the
beer with and T your m in the pub and
that that like side of the like it's not
masculine to talk about it I think that
that also means that you a lot of men or
at least for myself we don't have the
words to explain it a lot of the time
because we don't hear other men talking
about their body image issues or
struggling with the way they look other
than you know I were I went into like
the bodybuilding world and in that world
everyone talks about how much they
dislike their body but it's in this way
of everyone talks about iron therapy and
you're lifting weight so you're getting
better but no one ever spoke about it
with the context of maybe you're not
getting better um and also like kind of
on this subject of the the gender
differences I think with muscle
dysmorphia and mus muscle issues I'm
kind of seeing the other the other
stereotype coming in that everyone who
talks about it only mentions men and
there are there are women who and any
gender who also experienced this idea of
muscularity you know fitspiration for
women is such a huge thing now it's like
marketing it's the fact that when you
watch these adverts on the TV or you see
these magazines whether you're no matter
what your gender you're going to look at
something that captures your eye and you
want to almost look at that and be that
and you want to feel it because it's
kind of sold to you that if you're like
that you're going to live this like
powerful ultimate life and Men
especially by default are quite
competitive they're very you know it's a
pack thing
you want to be that really good-looking
guy with the good-looking partner and
the Beautiful kids if you so wish to
want kids and you want to have that
powerful job you want to have the good
hair and smell good it it's this whole
thing and if you're not that or you
you're you're looking at other people
that are that's where I think as well
that the feelings can be very valid for
men we have actual numerical evidence
now of of whether or not people that
kind of um are positive towards the way
you look you know and and the the issue
is that it isn't actually necessarily
linking to actually how attractive they
think you might be some people just like
for the sake of it but for me how many n
how many numbers I got below my picture
directly linked to how good of a person
I was that week I I think we do have a
responsibility and I I tried to use my
social media for good uh to show that
there are two sides of the same coin and
it's not all roses and you know I I'll
post pictures that I don't even like of
myself because I'm I want to be real you
know I'll do a no makeup selfie even
though I know that I feel vulnerable
doing it but then I know that it's not
natural to wear makeup every day for you
know 12 hours a day or whatever and
that's the same with filters I think
like I've been very mindful of not using
filters in fact actually weirdly during
my bdd when I was really bad I actually
would post without filters cuz then I
thought that's my real Stu that's how I
get
validation um but I also think now like
this day and age especially on Tik Tok
the filters just look so real and you
don't really know if it's real or not so
people just scrolling down are going to
think oh that's why am I not like that
why do I not look like that um so I make
it a very conscious effort I don't use
filters because like you said it's just
being real like I'm human I have pause I
have discoloration and texture which is
a normal human thing and it should be
celebrated rather than be fixed like
nobody has smooth skin that's just not a
reality I think I um definitely agree
with what you're saying like
authenticity embracing imperfections I
think that is where um the change
happens because I think if you can show
up as your authentic self okay yeah you
have the imperfections and you being
able to walk in that vulnerability which
is not hard it takes courage to do that
but I think when you show up as your
authentic self just
owning who you are and how you are it
allows others to be able to do the same
and I think that's literally like a
central message that I try to yeah um
you know share with others because yeah
there's power in that yeah I want to
talk now about um your individual
Journeys to recovery starting maybe at
your lowest point and the decision that
you made to to seek help or what helped
you move on um and start to take those
steps sure whenever I couldn't stick to
my diet or my exercise or whatever it
was that I was doing I used to lock
myself away in my room because I was so
ashamed of people seeing me behaving in
that way or I just so I felt like people
would be able to visually see that I
wasn't doing what I was doing even for
if it was for an hour and yeah that kind
of spiraled to me just not speaking to
anyone and just spiraling on these
emotions and these behaviors and getting
to the point where I was suicidal and
planning on on doing it and I was very
fortunate that my friend Cara came on
the day that I was planning on taking my
own life and she spoke to me and and I
ended up kind of breaking down crying
with her in my living room um and I
ended up hiring a counselor I worked as
a personal trainer ironically uh to hire
a private counselor and worked with him
uh weekly and the big thing that we
spoke about for one was I had this good
George and bad George and the good
George was this one that I showed
everyone where I got all the best marks
in at Uni I um exercised all the time I
stuck to this diet I looked really great
as I as far as I was concerned um and it
just was that and then whenever I
couldn't stick to these very rigid
behaviors I was the bad George and I hid
that away from everyone and the big
thing that he used to always talk about
was I had to become this other version
of George which was these two kind of
combined together and recognizing that
other people you know aren't going to
just hate me if I can't do everything
perfectly uh what I did this podcast
with a psychologist um Amy aiki name was
I I've always pronounced her last name
wrong so I'm sorry Amy um but she always
said that she said she speaking about
athletes but I think it aligns with me
as well that athletes who struggle with
their mental health they tend to build a
pillar and they put their their body
image and their athletic ability on this
base and then when they get injured or
something goes wrong the whole pillar
comes crashing down and instead what
people need to build and what I started
to build was a pyramid and I found all
these other aspects of myself that I
could respect about myself and like
about myself and love about myself and
then if my body doesn't look I want it
to look that day I can take it away in
the pyramid still standing yeah so I I
remember when I hit my rock bottom H it
was a it was a rainy day in Newcastle
would you believe it and uh I was I just
lay on my bed and I just couldn't do it
anymore um you
know it almost felt like I was just
being constantly battered by
waves um for every hour of every day I
couldn't spend 10 hours in the mirror
anymore I couldn't um you know take that
many photos and rip myself apart I
couldn't Purge my food I was really
weak um and I just I just couldn't do it
anymore it just it's just you know had
to all
end um and I remember being in the the
accident in emergency department
actually afterwards and and you know
feeling like I had a second chance um to
you know to kind of make things better
and there you know there's nothing like
being in a emergency department on a
Friday night to make you think think
about things um
and luckily um ironically both my
parents are mental health professionals
um handy must have seen me coming
um and I managed to get in contact with
the morsley in
London and uh and and I went down there
uh for 12 sessions of of support I was
very lucky to get that um and you know I
remember doing loads of exposure tasks
uh one of my one of my favorites was
walking down leam High Street with my
hair all messed up and you know wearing
Scraggy clothes like my worst nightmare
and there was one day just suddenly I
realize no one's looking at me no one
cares how I'm looking or no one's
fixating on that that little spot I've
got on the side of my on on my face no
one sees it it's only me that's that
sees it and I think slowly but surely
from that I started to build um kind of
resilience against my bdd my lowest
moment um was this one night where I
pretty much know St crying in my room
not being able to sleep um and it's
thoughts I had were dangerous and I was
really scared um I even remember looking
back at my notebook where I would write
such horrible things about myself just
you know this I'm ugly I'm this horrible
disgusting person um when I video myself
and I'm crying videoing myself
I think that was probably the lowest
part because it's a video of myself and
I'm crying because of the video that I'm
taking of myself and to other people it
just it
sounds ridiculous um I needed help so I
got the help I needed cuz luckily I was
in therapy for OCD but the thing that
really helped me was bit like you um
exposure therapy um going out the house
without any makeup on
um not curling my hair wearing clothes
that weren't really put together things
like that um and fighting community on
Instagram especially um finding the bdd
foundation completely changed the game
for me um I'm so thankful that I really
don't think I'd be here actually um if
they weren't here um that's the
importance of advocacy the importance of
there being resources out there knowing
there's so many
people feeling how I felt at my lowest
moment right now is it's makes me angry
it makes me sad it makes me want to to
talk about scream about it and um that
helps me as well speaking about my
experiences and I will continue doing
that um yeah I think my turning point
was um going to have cognitive
behavioral therapy at the mle as well um
we did a lot of exposure therapy um
which was super scary cuz I think for me
that was my last resort I'm like if this
therapy doesn't work for me then I'm
finished um but I'm so grateful that it
actually did and then I actually became
a Christian so I gave my life to Jesus
and I think my faith has been a solid
foundation for me which I've been able
to really understand and find identity
in and that has really kept me grounded
so I'm really grateful for that um but
also in that finding my purpose and
being able to utilize um the things that
I've gone through
um to actually Empower and speak to
others and actually find that level of
community um so that others can be free
as well because I think I didn't have
that um when I was suffering I thought
it was just me and so I always believe
that you don't go through um The
Suffering um without it turning into
something great when you have body
dismorphic disorder it doesn't feel like
there's any way out you feel quite stuck
um but we're all sitting here today you
know there's a camera rolling um and
that shows that there is a possibility
and there is hope for the future and so
I think I've been able to find purpose
and um joy in being able to heal but
then also be able to share that with
others which keeps me going I went for
the plastic surgery Journey which
obviously didn't go to plan and that was
the biggest wake up call because I had
this idea of what it was going to do for
me and I put all my trust into this
amazing doctor that was going to make me
feel the best I have ever felt and
obviously it went totally the wrong way
but in what you've just said like
through those hardships and and that
lesson that I've had to learn it really
made me stop and think hang on a minute
this is out of control and now I've gone
to the point of having plastic surgery
that's not given me the result that I
wanted and it's not even just the fact I
didn't like what I saw there were issues
with what he had done and the he in
process and whatever so there it was on
my face I had to live with it and I
thought what what do I do now cuz I
can't cut it off and I can't do anything
anytime soon to rectify it so I have to
live with the choices and the decisions
that I've made I got the opportunity to
speak publicly which then opened up that
whole Floodgate of people coming forward
to me which again shows that we're not
alone and that's powerful I felt
reassured I I do have Still Moments
where I can't believe I did that because
I've got a vlog cuz I was going to
record my whole process of plastic
surgery and how it changed my life well
it did but not in the way I wanted it to
and I look at the guy that's filming the
morning of his first surgery and I look
at him and I'm like why would you even
touch your face that is absolutely fine
and that was a pivotal moment when I was
then sitting there with my bandages on
after having a third uh surgery
thinking oh my God I need to this guy is
I need to find him again I need to find
the guy that
actually is more than just about a nose
or his image we're in a very fortunate
position that we can sit here strong and
come together collectively and find
these common denominators and that will
really help people so there is such a
light in that comes from these dark
places and I think that's just really
reassuring so that's I keep that in the
back of my mind even when the demon
starts creeping in and as we all know it
creeps in from time to time so that's
where I'm at I just finished my as
levels and I said to my parents okay I'm
going to get better I'm going to defeat
the
anorexia and I started going from I
would say 300 to 500 calories a day to
just eating 500 plus just for dinner so
I was really committed however there's
something thaten happens when you're
starved so long it's called the
refeeding syndrome so your body doesn't
know what to do with all this energy
that you're giving it so you start
losing weight dramatically so um I was
then I was under cams um and they said
either you go to hospital voluntarily or
we section you so I was in general
hospital for 10 days where I lost about
7 kilos even though I was on bedr there
was finally a place for me at a mental
health facility in Oxford which is about
60 m away from where I live um and I had
to be an impatient and I think my lowest
point was when I was checked in so I
used to keep uh I used to take pictures
of myself because I was so angry at the
anorexia and what it's robbing from me
so I have these pictures from when I was
my sickest and what what frustrated me
the most or kind of gave me that fire
was the fact that when I was
hospitalized in the mental health
facility I was not allowed to walk I was
on wheelchair rest so even if I wanted
to use the bathroom I had to wait for a
nurse to take me in a wheelchair I was
pretty much I was not allowed to stand
up I had to sit down at all times it was
very
dehumanizing that and also you know
having to pretty much strip down to my
knickers you weren't even allowed to
wear a bra because you could put stuff
in to make you weigh more so see you
know being treated by doctors and
they're seeing you in your most
vulnerable state
when you know even you know my mother
hasn't seen me that naked in years kind
of thing that was my lowest and I just
thought I'm not doing this anymore I do
sometimes look in the mirror and think
you know but then I I don't let it hold
me back because I'm like the
alternative is where you were when you
were 16 going back to the mental health
facility being that ill you know I'm
kinder to myself again I don't know if
I'll ever love myself that is a journey
I'm exploring through therapy and such
but I accept myself I forgive myself and
things could always be worse and now you
know I've helped so many people through
doing media appearances and writing
articles about my journey that it would
be very disingenuous to to go back to
that um there's not a lot of um stories
about women of color who have you know
had mental health problems or eating
disorders and such and I don't want
anyone to go through what we've all been
through you know what's so inspiring
about all of you guys you know you've
all used your experience to then help
others like every single thing that
you've done has inevitably prevented
someone else from experiencing the same
things honestly it's amazing it's well
done what would be the the early signs
to look for in yourself or in a loved
one um that they might be they might
have bdd or develop bdd and and any
advice you'd give to those people mostus
morphia is kind of a
uh maybe special case to some degree
with this at least in the I think the
the type of person um that we see in the
research in musod dysmorphia that people
tend to kind of lean in towards and I
say I don't want a stereotype but at
least from the average as we see um
there's this idea of vulnerable
narcissism vulnerable narcissism is
where someone deep down feels that
they're not worth it then not they're
not enough with as with body image
things in general people think about
vanity people think about you just want
to look attractive but trying to look
past that and recognize that for some
people this is all their insecurities
manifesting in something that you then
Define as they just think they're the
best and that's really really tough to
to spot but something that people need
to be kind of careful of and then
obviously with muscle dismorphia there's
the compulsive exercise behaviors and
kind of pulling yourself away from
social situations not going to parties
and and things because you're you need
to you feel like you need to exercise
and people in schools often have told me
there's one story that um a teacher told
me where they went on a school trip to
France and they had an hour window where
the kids were allowed to like explore
Paris and one of the kids and a few of
the boys Googled where the gym was the
nearest gym and went and trained for the
hour um you know obviously I don't want
to say that they definitely have musard
as Moria but those are the kind of signs
where you know it's that desperation
that I've finally got a moment I have to
do this and those kind of things are
stuff people need to work out for I
think also being a fitness professional
as well
and being around people that are
obviously trying to improve themselves
they come into the gym and they think
that you know you're going to help them
achieve the goal um I've come up against
so many people that you'll say something
like you're looking good today or you
know you're looking stronger or some
positive chat and the first thing they
do is no absolutely not or they'll pick
out the floor there's one person I know
that you know before you've even said
hello I've got a terrible spot on my
face and I I just they need to highlight
it first before you even engage in a
conversation because that's obviously on
their mind that they've got that and
they're aware of it so what I try and do
now and what I try and tell people to do
is when
someone's gives a bit of a negative
response to how they're feeling or how
they're looking is I don't just flip and
ly say oh you look fine you're good I
try now and use it as a way to actually
stop and actually give that person that
moment
or bank it in my head and think right
I'm going to come back to this with you
and just make sure that you're okay cuz
I've got that awareness I didn't think I
had a problem until my brother pointed
it out and he said you're punishing
yourself for eating a peace of fruit
like what's going on and then he told my
mom and my mom got me an appointment and
the doctor said okay yeah you've got bdd
you've got anorexia that kind of thing
so talk like even if you think that it's
all in your head and you're making
things up no just talk it's always
better and and that doesn't have to
necessarily be family I mean there are
members of my family who just absolutely
wouldn't understand because in our
community mental health doesn't exist
you know so sometimes it's friends
sometimes it's PE sometimes it's a
stranger who just notices something
about you like you said I would say
preoccupation
if you're spending a lot of time looking
at yourself in way one way or another
um I mean sort of that sort of thing um
I'd say maybe talk to someone like you
said um but it's the time spent I think
on your appearance and that goes into
how much you think about it as well not
just looking in the mirror or taking
photos it's the the mental side of it um
I mean I spent pretty much 24 hours a
day thinking about it up in my dreams
and um I think that's something to look
out for I think patience as well like if
you think your child or someone is
experiencing you know body image
difficulties whatever they may be
whether it be bdd or not just having
that patience to listen to them and not
get frustrated again going back to the
whole backstory thing and how my my
bullying and that low self-esteem really
was the the version of events that led
to bdd and this this real struggle with
my mental health in general I think if
we can get into the schools and in into
like those um environments of
educational environments early on when
the when the kids are impressionable and
teach them about whether it's the
filters and marketing and what they see
might not be real or if they are having
showing symptoms of Eating Disorders or
affected by their body image and it's
its impact on their Mental Health then
starting those conversations early or at
least letting them understand to a point
that what the help could be or where
they could access help and support I
think could be a real game Cher in the
long run it's amazing to hear all that
guys one more question you could say
something to your younger self what
would it be I would say to my younger
self that you're just a kid and it's not
your fault and just things get better
your life you know 14 years later is
pretty damn amazing and just maybe don't
love yourself because you're not there
yet but learn to accept yourself for who
you are and everything's going to be
okay that's I just you know I'm doing
some work in therapy um and I just
really want to go to my 16-year-old self
and give her a massive
hug I'd say just just be you um I think
it's it's easier said than done I'd say
um cuz I wasn't me at 16 years old you
mentioned a robot I think I was a robot
you know I felt like that I was so
routined everything was out of
control um and just try and enjoy your
childhood I think that that would be the
the thing yeah best made
plans I think I would say to my younger
self that you're
enough and that's it you're and I love
that absolutely um I think that if I
looked at my younger self I
would probably say don't be the island
that you think you need to be you just
hadn't found your right people and you
shouldn't ever let anyone dull your
spark because there are people out there
that want to see you shine and just
because I was being maybe put into
situations that were difficult for me at
times and that wasn't letting me be my
true self I I would just like to give
you that reassurance Charlie that you're
right people are out there and they're
going to make you shine and you're going
to have a great life so just buckle up
it's going to be bumpy but it will be
good I actually part of my therapy was
hanging up little pictures of little me
and sticking them up everywhere um and
she said to say the stuff that you say
to yourself to that
picture and it just made me cry because
that little girl I would never ever say
that I wouldn't want her to feel the way
that I was making myself feel um so
literally just say that you're beautiful
and amazing and that's not about your
appearance that's just who you are as a
person um and give her the biggest hug
um and also probably tell her to you
know not wear too many Disney princess
outfits out
but yeah that's why I
do I'm kind of struggling with this I
had so much time to think of it
but I feel
like something I was so obsessed with
when I was younger when I was struggling
with this stuff was that I thought
everyone else knew how life worked and
knew how you're supposed to do all these
things to feel good about yourself and
it just came natural to everyone I
thought everyone just got it and I was
just this confused and scared person
that was latching on to whatever he
could to try and prove that he was
something I guess I would tell myself
that no one's got it figured out and and
that's
okay